make sure you guys hit the subscribe
button if you guys are enjoying the
content that we're throwing up
and uh make sure you guys hit the like
button if you enjoy the video and
yeah let's begin
what's going on guys this is rob and we
are covering the beta ray build tie-in
for the king and black
it's kind of a tie-in but kind of not
marvel's actually launching a beta ray
build mini series it's gonna be like a
five issue limited series now here's the
thing to understand going into this
this is what we call a proving ground
story for those of you guys who have i
mean
that's not really a technical name but
those guys who are new to comics
whenever marvel and dc
bring in somebody usually somebody who
does indie comics they give them like a
proving ground story right so in dc
comics daniel warren johnson wrote
uh wonder woman dead earth and he
actually drew it too and then in marvel
he's doing this with lady ray bill
now they do this because they just want
to see if a writer
is basically capable of drawing and
writing or possibly just writing or
possibly just drawing
a particular comic that is not a huge
landmark comic right so you wouldn't
really see marvel give a proving ground
comic
like the fantastic four to someone like
daniel warren johnson right and if they
did it would be an out of continuity
story
that if it was poorly received due to
the writing in the art or whatever
marvel could just kind of throw it away
right now having said that not the
biggest fan of daniel warren johnson's
art his writing's fantastic
his writing is amazing but uh but the
art's a little
it's a little a little too wonky for me
right a little a little too off for me
uh but having said that so the cool
thing about this
is daniel warren johnson kind of touches
back on the origin of beta ray bill just
to smidge now just from what we see over
the course of this comic
most likely he'll be doing it
intermittently over the course of the
whole comic itself
i mean if you want to know like the full
on origin of beta ray bill i mean i
guess we could do that
i don't remember if we have a betty ray
bill explained video
like i don't know if we ever i don't
know if we ever explained beta ray bill
right if we didn't then we definitely
need to
but uh the long and short of this is
that betty ray bill's planet was
basically destroyed by surter
and so that's why when this comic opens
up you have one of the carbonites using
a
giant telescope basically and asking
what do you see and you know what's
coming and they say
fire right so basically sirter's on his
way to wipe out beta ray bill's world
now having said that one of the things
that happens here
is you basically have the the carbonites
that are you know at least the the
science divisions are kind of
established or the police force more or
less essentially the government
visiting a woman and then telling her
her child has been chosen right now the
reason why this matters all of you guys
who are unfamiliar with beta ray bill
the reason why this matters is because
what you had
was beta ray bill being selected to
essentially undergo a process
that turned him into a cyborg and so he
was effectively
established as the protector of the
corbynite race when they fled their
planet
and then took off into space trying to
find a new place to live now
in the original introduction that we
were given by um by walt simonsen
and then later on in some other
appearances that we saw in marvel comics
that's when he came into contact with
thor
right that he you know the the the
spaceship scuttlebutt which he uses to
you know as well at least that was the
the vessel that was being used to kind
of pilot his race and so on when it came
across earth
nick fury realized there was a vessel
there contacted thor asked him to go
visit him and vader ray bill got into a
fight bill lifted the hammer mjolnir and
then
of course that led to odin basically
giving him storm breakers so that's how
all that stuff kind of unfolds a quick
super simple synopsis of beta ray bill
that the important thing here is that
beta ray bill's stormbreaker has been
broken right it was broken by
thor during the first story arc by donny
cates when you had like the black winter
and all that kind of stuff now this is
an important thing to understand here
when it comes to build and this is why
daniel warren's john
danny warren johnson's handling of this
character is so cool is because it
almost deals with a kind of ptsd for
beta ray bill an important thing to
grasp here is that stormbreaker was part
and parcel to bill
you know being able to lift mjolnir the
hammer of thor while bill didn't realize
the significance of it
when he immediately did it that once he
once he was basically
at least once he spoke with odin and
odin kind of told him the enchantment of
mjolnir and the nature of it it really
kind of established the idea that beta
ray bill really is just one of the
greatest warriors
throughout the entirety of the universe
over the course of the various stories
that we've seen him involved in in
marvel comics
that belief and that identity that bill
developed for himself became even more
and more significant right to the point
that like him
and thor were effectively blood brothers
so what we're dealing with here is we're
dealing with the idea
that one betty ray bill's hammer is gone
right stormbreaker's gone and then two
it was destroyed by his closest friend
and so there's a lot of feelings of
betrayal and
and even probably depression that's this
kind of feeding into beta ray bill in
the aftermath of this
the other part of this though is that a
romance has kind of been brooding you're
kind of kind of been growing between
sif and beta ray bill which good for you
bill sits pretty hot
but uh nonetheless you know what romance
has kind of been been growing between
the two right and a lot of it comes out
of mutual respect now
a lot of this is due to the events of
the donnie kate's thor story called pray
if you're not currently reading that
story which we're on issue number five
pray is amazing i'm so excited to cover
that story
it's it's just it's a ridiculously good
thor story the the important thing here
is that a lot of respect has happened
between sif and bill
now it wasn't just the prey storyline
that led to that right remember bill's
been fighting alongside thor for
years and years and years and years and
years and stiff is not blind to that
right i mean thor you know uh betty ray
bill has proven himself as a capable
warrior
over and over again and so with the with
this force that's essentially arriving
here
bill's kind of like okay uh then less
martial let's marshal the forces right
because bill is basically the one he's
essentially a steward for asgard right
now right that you have thor on earth
who was fighting during the king and
black event and was essentially taken by
null
right and so as the steward he's
basically the guy kind of keeping an eye
on the kingdom while the king is away
and so with that being the case like
once the once this force
basically makes itself uh makes itself
apparent it turns out to be fenfang foom
now before you guys turn the video off
because i know some people are going to
be like man okay fin feng fume is one of
these guys
right i don't really know why daniel
warren johnson chose finn fang boom but
he's basically a throwaway character
he used to be awesome back in the day
like back at you back in the day when he
first showed up he was
awesome right it's just marvel's just
kind of reduced him down to the villain
of the week kind of thing right he shows
up fight somebody and then leaves and
he's kind of a villain
anti-hero depending on the story he's
never really been a good guy like he's
never really been a hero but the reality
is that he was taken by null and just
kind of brought here and then
you know all hell's breaking loose now
the reality of this is the fight's
pretty straightforward right there's not
a whole lot going on here he calls on
the help of of scuttlebutt you know
using its weapons on board the ship to
attack ben feng fume to kind of bolster
the forces of
of of the asgardians and fin fangfun
kind of gets the upper hand on all of
them right and you know some stuff
happens so people fight and you know
it's it's not the it's not the greatest
thing ever that's kind of the nature of
when you see him fight what's important
is what comes after this and so
ultimately where finn fang fumes able to
kind of
overtake these guys and and essentially
like sending the asgardians cowering in
fear right just
totally trashing asgard do not let the
fact that a spin thing fume and he's not
he hasn't been relevant in 15 years do
not let the
that fact lose you on the fact that he's
literally
single-handedly destroying asgard right
like fen fang boom is trashing asgard
we've only ever seen that happen a
couple times now this is happening
because thor's not here if i'm being
honest with you guys
if this was a time when like odin was
here odin would be like no and then he
would just destroy finn fang boom and
he'd be like dude like he's like man
like you've interrupted my breakfast
right like that's the thing about odin
man right
odin would crush finn fang foom and be
back to his castle in time for corn
flakes finn thank fume in the grand
scheme of things is not by any standard
of measurement
a colossal villain that like sends
heroes cowering in fear
the cool thing is while he is able to
get the upper hand on bill and all of
them which you know the fact that bill's
losing here is because of storm because
he doesn't have storm breaker
thor shows up with his hammer and then
basically overtakes the day right leo
overtakes everything and then it's kind
of considered the champion by uh by the
asgardians who welcome him back and
and vader ray bill's kind of left
hanging now that's where the downward
spiral begins right because
vader ray bill is the one who marshaled
these forces he's the one who fought you
know in
in the most hard way but thor is the
king of asgard and it's one of these
things where when he shows up because of
the name recognition because of the fact
that he is the king
he's always kind of been the greatest
warrior of asgard after after odin
stepped down as like a fighter and
basically became a king that when when
thor wins and it's just kind of like
cool thor saved us right and everybody
just kind of goes and hangs out with
thor so it's almost like all the
accomplishments of bill throughout all
of this are largely just being ignored
and that's something that kind of
bothers him right because thor doesn't
really do anything to step up and say
hey had it not been for beta ray bill
marshalling all of you guys you would
have been destroyed right like i came in
here and kind of mopped up but like the
glory belongs to bill none of that
happens thor's like yes
ladies it's because of me that the day
is saved and
we must go to my chambers and that's
basically how thor's acting at the
moment right
which i mean you know that's the spoils
of being a king right that's just the
way it goes when you're king
but you have pip the troll who kind of
shows up out of nowhere right it's kind
of like hey i heard there was a party
and bill's like
not right now dude so he ends up kind of
leaving he does he does almost kind of
get a reward right that he's met by seth
and sif just kind of like like where are
you going like why are you leaving and
he's like well you know i'm just not
she's like well then you owe me two
drinks now
right so like she leads him off to the
room right and it's like man beta ray
bill dude bait ray bill's about to get
some action son
and then as soon as he gets in there she
she asks like how does this work and
he's like well what do you mean she's
like your humanoid form
and that's when the reality dawns on
beta ray bill that sift didn't want him
the way he looks
now sif wanted him when he hit
stormbreaker on the ground and goes back
to his normal humanoid form right where
he's not really human looking but
looks like his race did before he
underwent all these different you know
enhancements by
by way of uh these cybernetic implants
and whatnot and so that's that's
crushing
for bill right because it's kind of like
okay so like you know as i look now
i'm not really attractive enough like to
get with you you want me to like look
the way that i
that i normally do right and she's kind
of taken aback she's like i mean
like don't you change back at night or
something like that and he's like no
like ever since stormbreaker was
destroyed there's no way for me to go
back to my normal self and during prey
sure
i was able to use milner and go back to
my normal stuff for a moment but like i
don't i don't possess that hammer right
i don't possess mjolnir it's not
it's not for me right stormbreaker is
the hammer for me and thor destroyed it
so i'm basically stuck
in this form and then she's just kind of
like oh so basically it's like okay well
like we're not gonna bang like that's
that's kind of what it is so literally
betty ray bill's just
just experienced sexual rejection
rejection from from sip
ask any man out there who's experienced
that and if if he tells you man it's no
big deal he's full of crap like any man
who's ever been rejected in that moment
is crushed i
promise you as sure as the sun will rise
he may not show you
but he has he's totally crushed right
that's just that's just the way it goes
and so from there it's one of these
things where you kind of do a momentary
flashback right to better rebuild when
he was a little kid and he was about to
undergo this surgical process
uh in order to become the hero of the
corbinites and he's he's very like he's
i mean he's a little kid right he's
horrified of what's about to happen
right he's terrified he has no idea
what's going to come out of this right
all he knows
is he's going to experience these kind
of enhancements and that's basically it
but as a child
this is when he's met with scuttlebutt
and so it's one of these things where
the scuttlebutt ai which you think walt
simonson could have chosen a better name
but the scuttlebutt ai is has basically
been his partner ever since he was a
little kid it's the only real friend
he's had
over the course of his life until he met
thor and now that thor destroyed his
hammer that friendship's kind of broken
on multiple levels and so scuttlebutt's
his fallback and so he's like you know
what will happen to me and scuttlebutt's
like i don't really know what's going to
happen but no matter what i i will be
with you
through it all right no matter what
happens i will be with you every step of
the way
and that's true the scuttlebutt ai has
always been there for beta ray bill has
always been a part of beta ray bill's
life it's the one thing he can always
count on and so because of that he's
just kind of like prepped the engines
we're out of here right and this is when
thor shows up and it's just kind of like
where are you going and
and bill's like i'm trying to get away
from here man like i thought we were
friends
like we're we're not friends like
apparently we're not friends at all like
i thought we were brothers in this way
one like i marshaled the forces of
asgard i'm the one that brought all
these guys together to face off against
fen fang fume
and then like at the end of the day like
despite no matter how hard we fought and
those that we lost you come in with your
hammer and your lightning you defeat
that you defeat finn thankful and all of
my accomplishments
totally overlooked right just completely
and totally ignored right and then
on top of all that the reason why i lost
defend fang fume and couldn't properly
protect asgard is because you you broke
my hammer right you destroyed
stormbreaker now the response of thor to
the first point is this
i can't control who i i can't control
that right it's who i am like i am the
king of asgard
so if i save the day people are going to
assume that i'm the reason why the day
saved and they're going to ignore your
accomplishments
that's what happens when the king shows
up and the king defeats the main bad guy
that the people who fought alongside him
the entire time
are largely just kind of ignored in that
way right it's just the way that kind of
thing works
and so to the second point thor doesn't
really even make one right like vader
rabil doesn't give him a chance he's
like ever since
i came to asgard i'm reminded of my own
failures right i'm reminded of the
things that i've done wrong
the mistakes that i've made so i need to
leave this place like i need to go and
find myself right i need to i need to
find
a hammer right i need to i need to find
odin and i need him to make me
a new hammer now as far as we're aware
odin's gone right so like i don't know
if odin really does exist out there
who knows maybe we'll find out over the
course of this and this might be one of
those stories where marvel uses as a way
to bring odin back right but whatever
the case is he's like i need to go i
need to have a new new
hammer forged for me right something
like stormbreaker not exactly
but something similar because he wants
to kind of go back to being normal right
he wants to go back to being the person
that he knew that he used to be right
and that's one of the that's one of the
most important things to take away from
all this
is that betty ray bill looks at himself
and is just kind of like i'm an ugly
person like i'm an ugly thing right he's
disgusted with the person that he sees
because everything that makes him who he
is and that he uses to define himself
is basically gone right having success
in his campaigns and saving asgard
completely overlooked because thor saved
the day
the the the hammer stormbreaker right
his identity is tied into that hammer
is gone he's experiencing an existential
crisis he doesn't know who he is where
he's going or what he's about
and the current i guess basis behind the
story is to go figure that out so with
that being said guys we're gonna bring
this video
to an end if you are new here to comics
explain make sure you guys hit the sub
button to become part of the rob corps
if you guys enjoyed this video
make sure you drop a like and i will
catch you all later
peace
[Music]
you